on time and so i'm happy to uh let
daniel introduce the next session and uh
changing focus from approachability to
the rao blackwell theorem
hi hey everyone thanks so much for
having me here i'm really excited to be
here to i mean
continue to honor the legacy of
cleveland blackwell so i'm daniel and
i'm going to talk about the real
blackwell theorem
and um
first of all i'm going to start by
very given a very personal view of david
blackwell what he means to me and how i
discovered david blackwell and i would
say i only recently discovered david
blackwell 2012 which is i would say like
very recent for a lot of people here
and then i'm also going to talk about
his ingenuity in spite of the odds he
faced throughout throughout his life
then i'm going to go to the black hole
theorem um i call it black level route
some people call it brow black or
theorem some people call it the brown
black old kamagor theorem
um but i'm just going to call it brown
black or mostly for this talk
okay so before i actually stick the
theorem and prove them i'm going to try
to motivate it with um sufficient
statistics if you don't know what that
is i'm going to actually try to
precisely find it
then i'm going to talk about
the theorem statement and then prove the
theorem which is i would say just one
slide
and then i'm going to try to apply to
privacy
via perturbing sufficient statistics
which again i'm going to define
and the notion of privacy i'm going to
use differential privacy introduced by
dorcadell it's a popular notion of
privacy that pretty much says that you
want to hide the effect of a single
individual when you're competing in a
statistic so for example let's say
you're trying to compute a mean
you want to be able to compute a mean
while hiding the effect of
of an individual so for example you
don't want to know let's say intuitively
if i'm in the data set versus if i'm not
in the data set and so we're going to
ensure that notion of privacy by
adding some noise to some sufficient
statistics right
okay so
now i'm going to start
all right so how did i discover david
blackwell again it was in 2012 so pretty
recent so i was in budapest in 2012 and
i was going to study abroad and if you i
mean know a lot about hungarians they're
really proud of vanilla
he's a hungarian mathematician i mean
some people say that he actually
founded game theory as a mathematical
discipline some people as in probably
hungarian say that
um and uh he's made a lot of
foundational i mean contributions to
mathematics in different uh dimensions
um so
yeah so in 2012 i took this class
about linear programming and i learned a
lot about game theory through the class
and i decided okay i'm just gonna post
to make a blog post and just post it on
some nice aggregator hacking news
and i got some comments um specifically
there was this comment
about
on vector pay-ups
and i think the the commentary was
really asking about zero sum games like
what does that mean and why are you
doing this and
um
even though okay i should have just i
mean responded okay this is a zero-sum
game and i decided to actually
investigate i mean are they like other
types of games
and i actually just started asking okay
about like vector payoffs and i googled
for it and then i discovered that david
blackwell actually asked the same
question about vector pf's
um yeah which then led me to discover
black holes approachability theorem that
megan and
ricky have talked about plentifully
um and so i was like wow i mean david
black this foundational mathematician
also asked the same question so
the question is like do all black people
think like this
perhaps they do right he's black and
black
um of course the answer is no right but
it was very inspiring to see someone who
looked like me
do i mean such foundational work
and i started reading a lot about him
discovering a lot of his works
um and yeah that just really led me on a
journey towards doing a phd
okay
so we know the stories that you've heard
i mean plentifully um we know he almost
got hired at berkeley in 1952. um he was
interviewed by statistician neyman and
uh naming supported his appointment but
the head of the mathematics department
also supported his appointment
but
unfortunately
there were factors beyond black cause
control specifically the wife of the
mathematics professor
did not support the appointment of
blackwell um because she just wasn't
comfortable with black people being
around right and so something beyond his
control really like led him to
um
be pushed
away from the path i would say for some
time
but eventually though he still made a
lot of contributions and in fact from 19
uh
from from the
from 1942 all the way to 1954 he still
made a lot of contributions in fact he
like wrote a textbook i believe so the
theory of games and cisco decisions
which he wrote when he was still like
around uh hbcus when he was in the
southern university uh baton rouge all
the way to um
uh when he was in howard university he
still made a lot of contributions um so
he didn't just like whit around he
actually still thrived in his capacity
which is i think very inspiring this is
something i tell a lot of my my mentees
a lot of factors that are not in our
control but we still have to make an
effort to strive to do our best right
and i think that's i mean an inspiring
story um
okay so
now i was still in the stage of trying
to figure out am i going to do a phd i
like math i like cs
but should i do it and reading things
like this i would say discourage me a
little bit right um i mean
i don't want to face the same challenges
that i mean by the face right um and so
the there were two questions am i
willing to be in the system and am i
ready to be in the system i was willing
to be in the system but i really wasn't
ready at the time
and so what really made me decide to do
a phd um was
this so i was
a volunteer at the citizens schools
and
uh
mostly there were brown kids there i
mean african-american kids hispanic kids
has my co-instructor ellen yep and this
was i think in 2015
and as you can see they're holding
kitkats and so every session will try to
lure them in like to come to class with
like kitkats and they will come a lot
and then towards the end of the semester
i asked um some of the kids like so did
you start coming just because of kit kat
and i mean some of them would say yes
but then one of them tyrone actually
told me that it really wasn't about the
kitkat that he saw someone who looked
like him right
teach teaching how to code and then at
the time i really just was like i guess
that's that's a comment right and then i
went home and then i thought about a lot
i talked to my friends about it
and so he was inspired by just my
existence just my presence right
me looking like him really inspired him
to i mean once you learn to code and so
the same way i was inspired by blackball
and so imagine if
i mean a lot more people were inspired
by people like like me or blackwell and
there could be a whole generation of
people i mean doing mathematical
sciences i'm believing they can do it
the same way that i thought i could do
it because black girl did it
um and so that's like i mean i would say
in my opinion the greatest contribution
of blackwell sure he's proved a lot of
themes he's made a lot of contributions
to science but his inspired entire
generations of mathematicians
statisticians computer scientists right
to think
he can do it and i can do it too and the
same holds for me and holds for a lot a
lot of other people
okay so i've talked about the first
contribution black hole's uh
inspiration to a lot of people
uh we've heard from negan we've heard
from
rakesh
uh black holes approachability theorem
pretty much extended von neumann's
mini max theorem 1928 of thinking about
scalar utility between two players to
vector pf's this talk is going to be
about the route black of theorem
um
and then we've also i think heard from
winner and uh
and uh srikant about
contraction mappings black also had some
contributions about sufficient
conditions for contraction mappings and
this also applications to dynamic
programming
um so that's an i think a very very nice
contribution also to mvps and
dynamic programming in general
and also i mean there's several quotes
about the way david blackhole was really
about understanding things
and less about just publishing for a
famous publishing sake
and inspires a lot of people too i mean
there's lots of quotations about oh yeah
i'm really trying to i don't really i'm
not really interested in research i'm
interested in really understanding and
to understand something you have to work
it out yourself
i'm not going to try to rehash all the
quotations but i think that's a very
interesting style of research
okay so
there's also books by david blackwell
there's a basic statistics books
apparently it's one of the first
bayesian statistics books
um and there's also another book fear of
games statistical decisions with
gershik that uh ricky i think mentioned
gurshay i believe was the rand
corporation when they collaborated on
this textbook
um and yeah so 1954 book and for those
familiar with just the title it's very
similar to the theater games and
economic decisions
by uh von neumann and uh
and morgenstern
and so you can see here there's some
influence between david blackwell and
von neumann and in fact i think when
david blackley was a postdoc at ies they
got to interact and
exchange ideas which was
interesting
okay so yeah so david blackhole
was an inspiration wrote books published
papers made contributions
and now i'm gonna try to switch gears a
little bit to talk about the rao
blackwell theorem
um
before i proceed any questions about
what i talked about
okay so the real blackout theorem i'm
gonna try to motivate it first of all
um and then i'm gonna state it
so in words i would say it's really
about
getting better estimators by using
sufficient statistics
i'm going to define what sufficient
statistics are first of all
okay
so suppose you have a distribution so d
theta so the distribution d theta is
parameterized by theta so this could be
let's say a normal distribution or a
bernoulli distribution and suppose you
have samples from the distribution
now we say t of x is a sufficient
statistic if the conditional
distribution of x given t of x does not
depend on theta this is the technical
definition
um i'm also going to give a like a
characterization of uh a sufficient
cystic and i'm going to give some
examples of what this is right and so
intuitively we're saying that if we have
a sample and we compute a function on
the sample
then the function t would be a
sufficient statistic
the function t evaluated on the sample
would be a sufficientistic if we can't
learn anything more about the
non-parameter theta
than from t of x that's the intuition
right
so for example you can look at this uh
sample right here one two three four a
hundred hundred hundred i clearly just
made this made this up
but uh let's say we're trying to
calculate the the population mean of
this uh
distribution from which the sample is
drawn from the median here is going to
be four
but
if you look at the sample we can clearly
see that i mean the population mean is
more likely to be closer to 100 than
close to four and so by looking at the
sample we can infer more about the
population mean so that tells us that
the sample median is not sufficient
for calculating population mean right
and so looking at this sample will give
us a lot more information
on the other hand
this sorry the sample median yeah is not
sufficient but the sample mean would be
sufficient because it would give us a
lot more information about what the true
population mean is so intuitively again
the sufficient statistic would give us
information about i mean
a lot more information
about calculating the
parameter of interest
that's intuition
okay so
we know the definition of division
statistics now
and now we're going to show by the black
overall theorem the real black ops
theorem
uh that we can rely on sufficient
statistics to get smaller msc msc is
going to be our notion of error right
okay so how do we know if a statistic is
sufficient there is a facial name and
factorization
that says that uh
t is sufficient if and only if there
exists non-negative functions g and h
such that we can factorize the pdf so f
of x is the pdf in the following way
right
so you could start it a little bit um
but yeah this characterizes if something
is a sufficient cystic or not
i'm going to give an example now
so suppose we have some sample right
drawn from a bernoulli distribution
the probability p is one the probability
one minus p is zero
now the joint pdf is given by
that over there
and so assuming independence we can
actually write out the pdf and collect
terms
and we get
that
we can factorize the pdf as the
following
so p raised to the power of t of x and
then one minus p raised to the power of
n minus t of x so t of x here is a
sufficient statistic because we can
factorize in the foreign way
and
in fact we can say h of x is equal to
the identity function
and g is equal to this expression over
here
and the key here is to notice that g
actually if you let me go back to the
last slide
g here only depends on x through t of x
right
and you can see here that is true it
only depends on
x through t of x and so because of that
t is a sufficient system and so in fact
this actually characterizes when
something is a physicistic oh no
okay so we know what sufficient cystics
are we know how to characterize surface
and statistics via efficient naming
and now let's talk about actually
reducing our notion of error the mean
squared error
okay so here's the definition
let theta be some
estimator we're trying to
some unknown parameter right
and let theta hat be some estimate of
that unknown parameter theta
now our notion of error is going to be
just pretty much how far
this data had is from theta
and this is the definition of mse and we
could break it into
a vice term and a variance term so
obviously if i mean this is an unbiased
estimator then we just need to reduce
the variance which will lead to reducing
the msc but in general we can't expect
all estimators data had to be unbiased
and so we could break down the notion of
air into a bystrom and a variance term
okay so
the story eventually is that we're going
to use sufficient statistics to
get
new estimators that will reduce the mean
squared error that is going to be the
main takeaway i would say
okay so now i'm going to pose a question
for the audience to make sure
they're with me so suppose we have a
sample n sized sample
and it's from a benoit distribution
probability p is a one it's probably one
minus p it's a zero
and so we define two estimators
uh one is like a sample average and the
second is a weird estimator it's x one
five which is one over five times
the first
sample and then plus four times the
second sample
so
this might be super obviously a lot of
people but which one is better
sorry
exactly it's a smaller variance thank
you
so if you look at the expected value
they're both the same they have the same
expected value
you can use linearity of expectations to
prove that
but if you look at the variance as we
said
significantly different in fact
the first one has variance that goes to
zero as n increases so as you get a
larger sample size it goes to zero
the second one that doesn't happen
so in fact
we see the following relation the
variance of the first one goes to zero
way faster than the variance of the
second one and so in general
we probably prefer estimators like this
right
x bar
so yes so the story here is that x bar
the maximum likelihood estimate is a
better estimator than x one five and
then you could ask is this general right
is this general
is the maximum likelihood estimate
always going to give us let's say better
msc than other estimators
anyone want to help you
that's true
that's where a very nuanced uh answer
asymptotically it will give you that
but
in this case for example we can actually
there are cases where the mle wouldn't
actually give us
uh the best in terms of msc
asymptotically it will
so to illustrate the point
let's suppose we have a sample for now
assume the mean is zero and the variance
term is here sigma squared
and now pay attention to this expression
here which i've i wrote on the board
over there
so it's like a sum of squares of
some term looks like an empirical
variance term right and it's a
sufficient statistic
and now the mle so the maximum
likelihood estimate of the variance term
actually is the following we can solve
it so we can get the pdf
uh you can get the log pediatric
derivatives estimate
sigma squared hat and get that mle is
the following term
and it's a biased so it's a biased
estimator and so you can then try to
unbias it and so it turns out this
actually is an advice estimate of sigma
squared
but even though it's unbiased actually
so now we have two estimators this one
which is biased by the mle and this one
which is unbiased but not the mle and it
turns out actually you can find another
estimator that actually cheats a better
msc
and i'm going to
tell you what the the estimator is
okay any questions before i keep going
at the settings my water
okay
so we're going to consider functions of
the the sample so x1 all the way to x m
and so
we're going to consider
functions that depend linearly on this
sufficient statistic s x x right and in
fact i'm only going to consider function
of this
sufficient cystic precisely i would say
motivated by the rao black ops here
which again i haven't really i mean
introduced but i'm just trying to
motivate and set the stage
okay so what's the msc of this estimator
so lambda s
xx
can be expanded to have this term over
here
and then further expanding it you get
uh
expectation of some lambda s x
squared term
and then you get some other terms
and it turns out
for example let me
actually just work this out
so
the expected value of this actually is
n
minus 1
sigma squared the expected value of the
variance of this term is
n minus 1 t
four
i would say okay believe me for this
term but i'm actually just going to
quickly work this out
so why is this
x minus x bar squared
and so
you can use linear expectation and
expand the terms
x i squared minus x bar squared
plus 2 x i
x bar
so expected value of all of this stuff
so luckily this coincides with the
variance of x i
so
we know we can get a sigma squared
term here
so this is a result in an n sigma
squared term here
and then this actually reduces to 2
x bar squared
because the summation would result in
this looking like n x bar
and so this would cancel out and so we
just need to really consider
just x bar squared the expectation of
this term
and you can work this out and get about
sigma squared of n
and so because this is summation
then there's going to be an n sigma
squared term here and for this term
we're going to get a minus
sigma squared over n times n term so we
get the expectation is equal to
n minus 1 times sigma squared and you
did something similar together variance
term
yeah okay so now we we know the variance
and we know the expected value
and we can just plug in the values
over there
and so we get that the second moment of
s of x x would be in this case the
variance plus uh
a function of the mean
and then we can just actually
use derivatives and solve for what value
of lambda would minimize the msc and it
turns out that value would be one over n
plus one right and so what have we done
we now have three estimators
s x x over
n the mle
which is biased
we have s x x over n uh n minus one
unbiased and then we have yet another
one s x x over
n plus one
not the mle
not unbiased
but it has a small msc all right
and now to see why we just relied its
statistics to actually come up with
those estimators
so the reason why pretty much is the rao
blackwell theorem
and now i'm going to try to stick the
theorem and then prove it here
but before i proceed any questions about
what i've just done
okay
all right so here's the real black hole
theorem
i call it the black hole ralph theorem
adam calls it the black law theorem two
and i searched in wikipedia and so it's
actually at the rao black will come over
there
um
which is cool uh
and so suppose there's like a theta
and uh suppose i'm trying to estimate
theta hat so i'm trying to estimate
theta via theta hat i have an estimator
it has bounded sigma moments
and now suppose t is sufficient we've
seen the definition of sufficiency and
we actually know how to characterize it
now by our efficient name
now suppose we can get like a new
estimator data star
using the sufficient statistics
then it turns out the datastar actually
would have
smaller
i mean would have
could have a smaller msc
than the original estimator and so this
actually is called throughout
blacklisation
and it's an important like operation you
can just do it once
um and a new one's point is that i mean
we're not actually guaranteed to get the
smallest msc possible
um
yeah i mean if it satisfies some
conditions like okay it's complete um
which is some technical definition
then we know okay we can get the best
unbiased estimator but
what we can just say is that we're going
to get a better estimator in terms of
messy that's all we're guaranteed
okay
so what's the proof i like it because
it's just one page
um so we have the definition
player star you plug it in
we get an expectation of theta hat given
t the sufficient cystic
but now we can use the narrative
expectation
to just bring this tater to this to
bring the t to this other side
and now we can use jensen's inequality
to then obtain this term
and then
finally to get from 9 to 10 you could
use the law of total expectation
to get
the final term
and so what we've proved here
is that
we got a new estimator we had a star via
black hole that
could have a smaller msc
than the original estimator
and that i think people referred to as
round blackalization
and in fact they actually let me use you
need to use gents as an inequality here
we just need to observe that variances
are not negative right and so the
expectation of some random variable
squared
is going to be at least the expectation
of the random variable l squared and
that's pretty much all we used here but
with jensen inequality we can actually
prove something more general
so for any lust function doesn't have to
be the msc
for any convex
loss function
we can get a smaller loss by using round
localization
okay any questions about this proof
thank you thank you
theater star is a new estimator
that depends on the old estimated theta
hat
that you would say in some ways it could
be improved an improved estimator that
uses the sufficient statistics
but precisely mathematically it's
yeah so given
specificity
of x
then you just get a new average based on
the old systick that i have
all right
i mean i would say it's because of the
law here or total expectation
the conditioning
right here
yeah yeah
well seven to eight we just we use
linearized expectation
to just uh
uh because theta doesn't depend on on uh
t
and so we're just able to just bring it
down here
yeah that's the question
we have functions
okay so yeah that's it so we have the
round black hole come over here
i'll probably check in the video at some
point and i'll probably see there's a
round black hole coming or someone else
here
um all right so that's it very uh yeah
that's this one page
okay so i have talked about the real
blackout theorem i try to motivate um
i've defined physicistics
and now let's just talk about an
application
okay so there's this notion of privacy
of the french privacy i would say it's
quite popular now
um and it's a way to ensure privacy of
individuals in a data set
so the point is if i'm the data set
versus if i'm on the data set
you want to
you want the adversary not to be able to
tell that
intuitively
and so
there's a definition
and there are mechanisms to ensure
and so the way mechanism just have
nothing to nothing to do with mechanism
design by the way it's an algorithm to
ensure
so the way people ensure the frontal
privacy is to for example add some
calibrated noise
to some statistic like the mean for
example or the sum
and it turns out you can add some noise
to
s of x x over there to ensure
differential privacy
i'm likely i'm not going to have time to
go over the specific application but i'm
just going to give you just
a very small snippet of the application
so we have a paper showing that for very
small data sets
from all homogeneous data sets so let's
say small variance data sets
you would have to use robust methods for
example median type methods like
tillstand and lystrim squares
to actually get small msc
but as n increases so as the variance
increases or the
sample size increases
while black hole kicks in you just can't
avoid you have to rely on estimators
that use the sufficient statistics
right
and so consider the simple linear
regression setting so we have
y dependent variable we have x let's say
a design matrix
and you can see this familiar term over
here
the sum of squares
right that we wrote over there this is a
sufficient statistic
and now
with differential privacy you're going
to add noise to entries in this
matrix here
and for now assume we're not trying to
protect how many individuals on the data
set assuming we just have to add noise
over here
right
and we know how to calibrate the noise
so we can add noise to this entry
and so intuitively you can see that as
if n is small
then we can add some noise that does not
depend on n
that could potentially obfuscate this
term
right
but as n becomes larger this term will
become larger and so the noise we're
going to add isn't going to really
change the sufficient statistic right
so we can see here that as the data set
size increases right whereas this term s
of xx increases or it gets really large
we're not going to add damage noise
and so we can rely on perturbation
statistics to ensure privacy
in the limit
and to get accurate estimates
of the slope and the intercept
yeah so that's exactly what i just said
but in this in the case where the
dataset size is small when n is small
you're gonna have to rely on robust
estimators like median type estimators
you can think of think of this
as n gets larger
then round black will kicks in you've
got to use the fitness statistics to get
better estimators that's the story
okay so anyways just to conclude um
clearly i've been very inspired by david
blackwell i am here really by
his inspiration throughout um he's
inspired not just me but a lot of people
um i'm done with the phd and
will probably uh stick around in
academia because i mean i've been spied
by him and a lot of other people
and so yes this is i think maybe a neat
message but
we definitely need more black holes uh
to inspire more people like me
um and yeah so this concludes my talk
and i'm very happy it's very honored to
have been here to see more about how
blackwell personally affected me
and here just some references and thank
you for your attention
let's take a couple questions and uh
wherever you are
then you can come up and start plugging
in
so yeah question
so sorry i may have missed this but you
said s x x x upon n plus one is
oh so so the round black hole uh theorem
just says you can use this statistic to
improve an estimator but it doesn't
necessarily say that you should use a
specific estimator
um yes i didn't make any statements
about that being the best or not being
the best but is it a raw blackwell
estimator i'll derive from some other
yeah exactly yes it is
so
for example you can say okay remember
the x15 estimator i had
he had access to the entire sample but
just used the first and the fourth stamp
uh first on the fifth right
so to rail black hole the round black
lies that you can just use more of the
sample right the sufficientistic and in
fact s of x x to improve that previous
estimation and so we can see that i mean
s of x of x
is a rao block lization right because it
uses more of the sample and in fact
using using the sufficient justice s of
xx
yeah
if that makes sense
yeah let's talk about r5 yeah
um but i didn't make any claims about
that being actually
the best ever
again the conditions like completeness
um that ensure you can get
the best
unbiased estimate right best in terms of
msc
but i didn't make any claims about that
but let's talk more about it
so
[Music]
okay uh so our last talk in the motoring
session we've heard a lot about you know
specific results and i think uh in this
talk we'll hear a lot about the approach
to research uh okay
so and floor series thank you thank you
for inviting me yeah thank you
it's really an honor